وفي مخيم النصيرات رصدت كاميرا مراقبه
استهداف غاره اسرائيليه ثلاثه مواطنين كان
الجيش الاسرائيلي قد طلب منهم اخلاء
منازلهم وقال شهيد عيان ان قوات الاحتلال
استهدفت الضحايا عندما شرعوا في الخروج من
منزلهم لحظه استهداف طاره استطلاع لثلاث
اشخاص ثلاث اشخاص
مدنيين تم توثيقها في 1/1 2024 الساعه 10
صباحا من كاميرا المراقبه عندي في البيت
طبعا هذا الشخص انا ما رح اذكر اسمه خوفا
على انه بيتي يستهدف لانه ممكن بيتي يخبطو
يعني فهذا الشخص هم اليهود اتصلوا فيه
وقالوا له اطلع من البيت على المنطقه
الامنه في دير البلح خلوه يطلع ويصل
للمفترقين اناه او طائره استطلاع واستشهد
على الفور فورا
استشهد هلقيت
اخوه للشب بحاول انه انه يروح يشوف هو
حيكون ماشي جنب الصور بحاول انه يشوف اخوه
مصاب او مستشهد احن هيك الفلسطينيه بتدب
حالنا على الموت لاجل انه نساعد غيرنا هي
الشخص هذا بيكون اخوه اسمه غازي تركوه يصل
لعنده وما استهدفوه عشان يعطوا الامان
للشخص الثالث اللي هو بيكون ابن عمي طبعا
الاول اثنين اي استشهدوا على الفور و وابن
عمي ضله ينزف لحد ما تصفى
دمه